what are collinear and coplanar points
how many lines can be drawn through one
point we can draw one like this another
one like this and many more
infinite lines can be drawn through one
point what about two points how many
lines can be drawn passing through both
these points just one one and only one
line can be drawn passing through two
given points now here's an interesting
one how many lines can be drawn passing
through three given points okay look at
these three points we cannot draw a
single line passing through all three of
these points but if we have three points
placed like this where exactly one line
passes through them then the points are
called wholly near points remember three
points are collinear if exactly one line
passes through each of them then what
are these three points called simple
they are called non collinear points
collinear if one line passes through
them non collinear if a line does not
pass through them so wait three
collinear points are special they form a
line but what's special about three non
collinear points three non collinear
points form exactly one plane if we have
three non collinear points like this
exactly one plane will pass through them
will four or more non collinear points
always former plane not necessarily but
if they do they are called coplanar
points understand these concepts were
three points are collinear if exactly
one line passes through them exactly one
plane passes through three non collinear
points and a four or more points form a
plane they are called coplanar coplanar
is basically one plane so whether two or
more lines coplanar easy if the lines
lie on one plane they are coplanar two
or more lines lying on the same plane a
called coplanar lines when are two lines
not coplanar if two lines do not lie on
the same plane like this then they are
non coplanar and we look at one last
combination of a line and a point will
they lie on one plane yes a line and a
point will always lie on a plane exactly
one plane it doesn't matter how you
position the point or the line you can
move them both as you wish you will
always have one plane passing through
them